here with reaction author of the number
one New York Times bestseller the Russia
hoax the illicit scheme to clear Hillary
Clinton frame Donald Trump Fox News
legal analyst Craig Jerrod also Fox News
contributor Sarah Carter and Ohio
Congressman Jim Jordan thank you all
congressman let's start with you because
we now have a situation where Glenn
Simpson won't testify Rod Rosenstein
won't testify yeah Congress doing their
job of oversight has been obstructed the
entire way and and you wait years and
you still don't get documents and they
never told the court in FISA about the
political origins meaning Clinton bought
and paid for all this yeah no you're
exactly right there's a pattern here we
should compel Glenn Simpson we should
make him come out and to come to
Congress and actually ascertain his
privilege he shouldn't just be able to
phone it in he should have to come there
but understand what they're trying to do
they're just trying to run out the clock
they actually want the Democrats to win
and if the Democrats win they're never
going to be called in front of Congress
and we'll never get the answers for the
American people that's their goal and
Simpson is just part of a bigger pattern
lois lerner at the IRS targets
conservative she takes the fifth Bryan
Pagliano sets up Clinton's emails system
and email server he takes the fifth in
front of Congress and now glyn simpson
the guy hired by the clinton campaign
who went out and hired Christopher steel
to put together the fake news dossier
he's taken the fifth and frankly I'm
tired of it and I know the American
people are you know Sarah you got now
the political origins that was literally
never told to the FISA Court for
warrants the bulk of information is the
phony dossier he again helped put this
thing together with Christopher Steele
and beyond the fraud now you have this
institutionalized obstruction and the
people involved they won't even talk
about it
they won't even they don't go to
Congress they won't hand them documents
on it well which is the reason why
Congress should subpoena rod Rosenstein
that should be on their agenda and this
is the reason why Glenn Simpson should
be found in contempt if he doesn't come
and discuss this before Congress we know
a couple of things Shaun a based on the
reporting today based on sources that
I've spoken to you it appears that Glenn
Simpson lied and if he did he needs to
explain himself in the
something Congress should hold him
accountable for Glenn Simpson remember
he was the one that was apparently
spreading all of the stories about the
Alpha server the Russian bank that was
communicating with Trump Tower and then
we eventually figured out based on
evidence that that was not true the FBI
threw that out the minute they started
looking at it but it didn't stop Glenn
Simpson from spreading malicious lies
through the media which he was doing
even with the dossier I mean the over
and over again we've said this Sean it
looks like the Hillary Clinton campaign
and the DNC were the only ones colluding
colluding with fusion GPS colluding with
British Foreign Intelligence asset a
former Christopher Steele who was then
colluding with the Russians there is no
evidence that President Trump had any
kind of collusion or communication with
the Russians during the election so the
entire special counsel was really based
on false premises it was based on it but
now it all begins to fit together Gregg
Jarrah and that is that now we know what
the leak strategy was about because Lisa
page had said oh there's no evidence of
Trump Russia collusion Peter struck even
said there's no there there so nine
months in they had absolutely nothing
right so then the leak of the dossier
begins to create the impression that
something had happened but that's
Hillary's bought and paid for Russian
lies sure you know irony of all ironies
and then we got guys apparently talking
about wearing a wire against the
President of the United States and maybe
trying to invoke the 25th amendment you
know President Trump said recently I
don't have an attorney general and he's
right about that on the very first day
in office Jeff Sessions began his
recusal from the case if the President
had a real incompetent attorney general
he would have called Comey into his
office and said show me your evidence
and that attorney general would discover
there was no evidence he would have said
show me the evidence in the FISA warrant
applications to spy on the Trump
campaign and would have discovered that
it was all conjured by Hillary Clinton
based on fabricated evidence and that
good incompetent Attorney General
would have marched over to the White
House and told the president you must
fire james comey for violating a myriad
of regulations and launched a serious
investigation in front of the grand jury
into the Russia it sounds like we're
getting there though because now you
have you know with James Baker's
testifying and Lisa Paige apparently
telling some truth and Andrew McCabe in
trouble they all seem to be turning on
each other here's the question will we
ever get the Declassified unredacted
302s gang of eight information the FISA
warrants and do you all believe that
this is now coming to a head and
backfiring and people will pay the price
Jim Jordan yeah I think we should get
all that information we have asked for
it multiple times if you remember a few
weeks ago the president icily said he
was going to now he's gonna run it
through the inspector general so
hopefully soon we get it Sarah oh
absolutely I think the 302s will come
before anything else but I certainly
believe that the gang of eight documents
and the FISA will also come maybe even
after the election that might be a
little bit of a wait great well the rats
are trapped in a cage and they're
knowing each other and they're gonna
turn each other in and sing like
Canaries okay great this very
descriptive word Smith a very good job